.
* Ruhige, gefühlvolle Gitarrenmusik *
Mit über 30 zu heiraten war Glück.
Aber ich habe aus Liebe geheiratet.
Als ich nach China kam,
war das Ziel,
eine Familie zu haben.
Wir sind an einem Punkt,
an dem wir wieder neu beginnen.
Das letzte Drittel des Lebens.
Ich habe mir nie so genau überlegt,
ob ich jemanden
aus einem anderen Land kennenlerne.
Es ist nicht so,
dass ich es gesucht habe.
Das ist ja nie ganz einfach.
Sag du.
Was hast du über mich gedacht?
Eigentlich gar nichts.
- Nichts? Nicht allzu viel.
Er ist ein guter Mann.
Er hat einen guten Kopf.
Zwei Länder, eine Liebe -
das ist "Hin und weg".
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Forever you and me.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Im Expat-Quartier Venice Garden
in der chinesischen Stadt Wuxi
ist es Morgen um 7 Uhr.
* Handy *
Mathias bereitet sich
auf seinen Arbeitstag vor.
Seine Frau Sharon und Baby Jonathan
sind noch nicht wach.
Meistens schlafen sie noch.
Dann gehe ich einfach.
Ich wecke sie nicht auf.
Manchmal überprüfe ich via Kamera,
ob Sharon wach ist.
Wenn sie wach ist, gehe ich rasch
vorbei und sage Guten Morgen.
Aber noch tut sich nichts.
Ich lasse sie schlafen.
Wir haben eine Kamera im
Schlafzimmer und eine im Wohnzimmer.
Das ist für mich gut,
wenn ich arbeite.
So kann ich von Zeit zu Zeit
schauen, was los ist.
Wenn ich alleine zu Hause
in der oberen Etage bin,
kann ich überprüfen, was er unten
in seinem Spielbereich macht.
Dass man in China
solche Kameras hat ...
Es ist eine Babykamera.
Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich.
Auch Mathias' Schwiegermutter
lebt bei ihnen.
Die Verständigung
ist nicht ganz einfach.
Wann bist du wieder zu Hause?
Etwa in einer halben Stunde.
Ich konnte mich
in dieser Zeit gut anpassen.
Die Art,
wie ich mit ihr kommuniziere.
Und auch sie.
Sie benutzt teils englisch Wörter.
Das ist cool. Die Kommunikation
funktioniert so recht gut.
Und dann über das Smartphone
mit dem Übersetzer.
So funktioniert es gut.
Venice Garden
gehört zu den besseren Wohngegenden.
Die meisten Nachbarn sind Expats
wie der Appenzeller Mathias.
Es war das erste Quartier in Wuxi,
in dem sich Leute aus dem Ausland
überhaupt niederlassen durften.
7,5 Mio. Menschen
leben in dieser Stadt.
Zur Metropole Schanghai
sind es nur 150 km.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Mathias pendelt mit dem Auto.
Die meisten Angestellten
kommen mit dem Shuttlebus zur
Schweizer Maschinenbaufirma Bühler.
Morning.
Der 36-jährige Mathias
ist Chef des Qualitätsmanagements.
(Englisch) Wie geht's?
- Gut, danke.
Wir haben ein kleines Problem.
Der Flaschenhalter
wurde ausgewechselt.
Ja, von 35 auf 50 l.
Wir können nochmals abklären, ob wir
dieselbe Lösung wie dort nehmen.
Aber die ist ziemlich teuer.
Jonathan.
Hallo. Good morning.
Jonathan. Hey.
Zu Hause ist Jonathan erwacht.
Mathias' Frau Sharon
kümmert sich um ihn.
Auch ihre Mutter
ist begeistert vom Familiennachwuchs.
Su-su-suuu!
Ich war überrascht
und habe mich sehr
über ihre Schwangerschaft gefreut.
Sharons Mutter macht den Haushalt.
In China ist die Familie wichtig.
Dass man mit der Mutter unter
einem Dach lebt, kommt häufig vor.
Als ich schwanger war,
weihte ich sie ein.
"Ich bin schwanger.
Ich brauche deine Hilfe."
Natürlich habe ich das auch
mit Mathias besprochen,
ob wir unsere Mutter
zu uns holen sollen.
Mathias war einverstanden.
Für die 60-Jährige
war es eine grosse Umstellung.
Sie kommt aus Changchun.
Diese Stadt im Nordosten
ist 1'500 km weit weg.
(Chinesisch) Sie sagen mir schon,
was sie denken.
Meine Tochter sagt mir oft,
was ich machen soll.
Ich finde das gut.
Früher konnte ich vieles nicht.
Z.B. den Geschirrspüler.
Ich fand ihn zu kompliziert
und glaubt, dass ich von Hand
viel schneller abwasche.
Es hat ungefähr ein halbes Jahr
gedauert, bis sie sagte:
"So ein Geschirrspüler
ist praktisch."
"Ich sollte ihn öfter benutzen."
* Heitere,
chinesisch anmutende Musik *
Warum Mefia
in die Schweiz gekommen ist,
und ich nicht
nach Ghana gegangen bin,
war wohl aufgrund
von gesellschaftlichem Druck.
Das tut man einfach nicht.
Wenn du hier einen Europäer
kennenlernst, gehst du nach Europa.
Dann hast du es geschafft.
- Ja.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Aber nach 13 Jahren in der Schweiz
sind Beda und Mefia mit ihrer Familie
zurück nach Ghana.
Heute besuchen wir mit Mefia
ihre Mutter, die auf dem Land lebt.
Wo wohnt sie? Mitten drin?
Ja.
3 1/2 Std. von der Hauptstadt Accra
entfernt lebt ihre Mutter hier
mit vielen Verwandten.
Da.
Hier geht es rein.
* Freudiger Ausruf *
Hello. Good morning.
Good morning.
- Hey, Beda.
Hello.
Das ist die Mama.
- Das ist sie jetzt.
Mona. Nice to meet you.
Damit ich es verstehe ...
Wer lebt hier alles?
Das ist die Mama.
- Ja.
Cousinen.
Sind das Cousinen von dir?
- Ja.
Dann meine Tante und meine Onkels.
* Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
* Sie spricht
eine ghanaische Sprache. *
Sie sagt: "Wenn du nicht lachst,
kommen die Menschen nicht zu dir."
Darum ist es wichtig,
dass man lacht.
Oh. That's very good.
Zu der Gastfreundschaft in Ghana
gehört immer auch ein warmes Essen.
Die ganze Familie hilft mit.
Kakaobohnen.
Noch nicht getrocknet.
Siehst du?
- Immer noch etwas feucht.
Bist du hier aufgewachsen?
- Nein. In Tarkwa.
Tarkwa
ist berühmtes Goldgräbergebiet.
Dort gibt es viele Goldminen.
Die meisten Goldminen von Ghana.
Haben dein Vater und deine Mutter
in den Goldminen gearbeitet?
Ja, mein Vater.
Wie viele Geschwister hast du?
Wir sind sechs.
Fünf Jungen und ein Mädchen -
das bin ich.
Aufgrund des frühen Todes des Vaters
ging Mefia schon mit 15
in die Grossstadt Accra arbeiten.
Eine schwierige Zeit.
Später konnte sie eine Ausbildung
als Coiffeuse machen.
Seither unterstützt sie ihre Familie
auch finanziell.
Ob mit oder ohne Geld -
ich habe mich nie verändert.
Auch das Reisen hat mich nicht
zu jemand anderem gemacht.
Ich bin stolz, hier zu sein.
Manchmal mache ich Ferien hier
mit den beiden Jungs.
Wir bleiben für drei Tage
oder eine Woche.
Ich komme immer gerne
hierher zurück.
Es sind zwei völlig andere Welten.
Man findet sich aber trotzdem,
und es funktioniert.
Das finde ich cool.
Zum Mittagessen gibt es
das Nationalgericht von Ghana: Fufu.
Das wird
aus Kochbananen und Maniok gemacht.
Auch eine Sauce gehört dazu.
Die heisst hier Soup.
Esse ich das mit den Händen?
- Ja.
Nicht kauen.
Fufu kaut man nicht.
- Nicht?
Das ist schon gestampft.
Ja.
* Mona lacht. *
So?
Hauptsache, es kommt in den Mund.
* Entspannte Musik *
Am Nachmittag
führt uns die Mutter zum Haus,
in dem Mefia und Beda
vor 15 Jahren geheiratet haben.
Es war schön.
Und traditionell.
Es war sehr heiss.
Ich habe stark geschwitzt.
Meine Eltern auch.
Und dann kam noch
die Trommelgruppe aus Accra,
mit denen ich lange gespielt habe.
* Trommelklänge *
Was habt ihr getragen?
- Wir trugen dasselbe.
So etwas wie Spitze.
- Etwas Weisses.
African Style. Aus demselben Stoff.
Wurde das speziell angefertigt
oder für den Anlass gekauft?
Eine Anfertigung.
- Genau.
Irgendwann ging es plötzlich los.
Und der DJ mit dem Sound System ...
* Lärmgeräusche *
Und der Pater: "God bless you."
Nach 2 Std. wurde Essen verteilt,
in Tüten.
Take-away. Als die Leute das hatten,
gingen sie weg.
Es war so kurz.
Hier oben ...
* Lärmgeräusche *
Und dann war es wieder vorbei.
Hast du dir eine traditionelle
Hochzeit gewünscht?- Ja.
In Ghana macht das jeder.
Wenn du das nicht tust,
bist du nicht verheiratet.- Okay.
Und immer noch Single.
Ihr dürft euch jetzt küssen.
Es ist der Moment.
Wie an der Hochzeit.
- Ja.
* Leichte Musik *
So.
So nice.
Wir haben geheiratet, weil wir uns
gern haben, weil wir uns lieben.
Und natürlich auch
für die Familienplanung.
Wir wollten Kinder haben.
Das wollten wir ermöglichen.
Dazu muss man verheiratet sein.
* Sanfte,
chinesisch anmutende Musik *
Während Mathias arbeitet, gehen
Sharon und ihre Mutter einkaufen.
Bevor Jonathan auf der Welt war,
machte Sharon
Karriere als Geschäftsfrau.
Bei der Heirat war sie über 30.
In diesem Alter
gilt man als Frau in China
schon fast als hoffnungsloser Fall.
Aber ihre Mutter, die geschieden ist,
habe sie nie verkuppeln wollen,
wie das viele andere Eltern machen.
Meine Mutter ist sehr glücklich,
dass ich Mathias geheiratet habe.
Er kümmert sich um die Familie
und ist eine sehr offene Person.
Er akzeptiert kulturelle
Unterschiede und andere Denkweisen.
Die Schweizer Firma Bühler
ist weltweit tätig
und hat alleine in China
3'200 Angestellt.
Morning.
Heute nimmt Mathias mit seinem Team
eine Maschine ab.
Was ist das Problem?
* Sie sprechen unverständlich. *
Es wird viel diskutiert.
Aber die Probleme direkt anzusprechen
ist in China nicht üblich.
Diese Maschine muss jetzt raus.
Alle wollen das Gesicht wahren.
Man will keine Person, v.a.
nicht den Manager, blossstellen.
Man widerspricht nicht.
Und ...
Aber ich weiss
um diesen kulturellen Unterschied.
Für mich ist es im Alltag
ein kritisches Thema.
Immer noch.
Darum kann ich in so einer Situation
entsprechend reagieren.
Das ist dasselbe.
Später müssen wir es markieren.
Auf dem Weg in die Kantine
checkt er die Kameras zu Hause,
um seinen Jungen zu sehen.
Ich vermisse ihn.
Ich bin einfach neugierig.
Ich schaue ins Wohnzimmer rein
und sehe, was Jonathan macht.
Was gibt es heute?
Gesundes Gemüse.
Meistens
fällt die Mittagspause kurz aus.
Länger als 20 Min. dauert sie selten.
Mathias lebt seit sieben Jahren hier.
Die Firma Bühler
kann ihn aber jederzeit
in die Schweiz zurückbeordern.
Bezüglich Arbeit wäre es okay,
wieder in die Schweiz zu gehen.
Es stellt sich eher die Frage, wie
wir das als Familie machen würden.
Ob Sharon auch dabei wäre.
Grundsätzlich
würde sie mit in die Schweiz kommen.
Es würde aber
die ganze Familie betreffen.
Das müssten wir diskutieren.
In der Markthalle
ist Sharons Mutter in ihrem Element.
Zu Hause
ist sie für das Essen zuständig.
Und sie hat den Überblick
über das Haushaltsgeld.
Meistens kocht sie zu Hause.
Sie weiss am besten,
was wir einkaufen müssen.
In diesem Markt
gehe ich einfach hinter ihr her.
Mutter und Tochter
haben ein herzliches Verhältnis.
Für Sharon ist klar:
Ein Umzug in die Schweiz
kommt nur infrage,
wenn ihre Mutter auch mitkommt.
Es entspricht nicht unserer Kultur,
die Eltern allein zu lassen.
Wir sollten uns um die Eltern
kümmern, wenn sie alt werden.
Das ist der Kreis des Lebens.
Wenn wir jung sind,
kümmern sie sich um uns.
Wenn sie alt werden,
schauen wir zu ihnen.
Wohin ich auch gehe, du kommst mit.
Aber klar doch.
Ich lass dich doch nicht allein.
Als wir uns entschieden haben,
zusammen zu leben,
liessen wir niemanden
zwischen uns kommen
und hörten nicht auf diejenigen,
die nicht auf unserer Seite waren.
Nur ein paar wenige.
Mein Vater hat sie geliebt
und sagte immer:
"Endlich hast du
die Richtige gefunden."
"Sie macht dich glücklich."
Das tut sie immer noch -
seit elf Jahren.
That's what it's all about for us.
* Träge Country-Klänge *
Seit elf Jahren
wohnt Brigitte mit Jay
in diesem Reservat
von Native Americans.
Ihr Mann Jay
gehört zum Stamm der Nakoda.
Er ist sehr spirituell.
Von ihm hat Brigitte
auch das Morgenritual übernommen.
Es ist ihre Art, dafür zu beten,
dass sich Jay schnell
von der Krebsoperation erholt.
Ja. Hm?
Da hast du dein Zeug.
Damit kannst du spielen.
Nicht wahr, Bubu?
Psychisch gesehen ...
Ja. Er ist zu Hause.
Er kann zu Hause im Bett schlafen.
Er liegt neben mir.
Das gibt ihm wieder
positive Energie.
Und bezüglich Kraft ...
Es braucht seine Zeit,
bis er wieder genügend Energie hat.
Es kommt schon gut.
Ich schaue,
wie es in der Schweiz aussieht.
Wir müssen einen guten Arzt finden.
Brigitte
zieht es schon lange in die Schweiz,
näher zu ihren Töchtern.
In zwei Monaten soll Jay nachkommen.
Das haben sie
schon vor seiner Krankheit geplant.
Es gibt viel zu organisieren,
z.B. eine Krankenkasse finden.
Ich habe
mit mind. 600 Fr. gerechnet.
Weil er jetzt eine Chemo braucht und
wir Ausgaben für Medikamente haben,
liegt ein Auto nicht drin.
Zum Glück ist 100 m entfernt
eine Busstation.
Und im Sommer das Motorrad.
Die Umzugsfirma ist bereit.
Jetzt wird der grosse Umzug
Wirklichkeit.
Es ist Jahre her,
seit ich zuletzt in der Schweiz war.
Schön, die Familie wiederzusehen.
- Ja, ich freue mich wirklich.
Alles hier muss mit.
Und die Schallplatten.
Und hier auf dem Tisch.
Das nicht.
Aber die Lampe und der Schädel.
Jay muss sich
nach seiner Operation noch schonen.
Er bleibt gelassen -
trotz des Wirbels rundherum.
I got it in.
Really?
- Yeah.- Perfect.
Aus Sicht der Native Americans
ist alles so gekommen, wie es muss.
Wir haben sogar schon
eine Wohnung da drüben.
Ihre Tochter
hat sie uns eingerichtet.
Die Visa,
die Flugtickets, der Hund -
alles ist so,
dass wir jetzt gehen können.
Oh, my baby.
Wir werden ihn
in der Schweiz wiedersehen.
Es ist real. Wirklich real.
Ich muss mich setzen.
Ich kann nicht länger stehen.
Bye. Thanks guys.
- No problem.
Der Abschied kommt näher.
Bald sind die beiden
für zwei Monate getrennt.
Umso mehr geniessen sie
die gemeinsamen Momente.
Oh boy.
Oh, yes.
Für dich Wein.
Und für mich gibt es Limonade.
Okay.
Wir heben die Teller
und bedanken uns beim Schöpfer,
der Mutter, dem Vater,
unseren Ahnen, dem Universum
für Essen und Freunde.
En Guete.
- En Guete.
Wie schön.
Wir sollten das öfter machen.
Die beiden wissen,
was sie aneinander haben.
Und sie sind dankbar
für ihre späte Liebe.
Es gibt nichts Vergleichbares.
Sie kommt immer an erster Stelle.
Ich kann nur sagen: Das ist Liebe.
Ich würde alles für sie tun.
Und ich weiss,
sie würde alles für mich tun.
There you are, sweat pea.
That's the sweet pea I know. That's
what I love about this woman.
Vor elf Jahren
zog Brigitte zu Jay nach Montana.
Weil das Heimweh nach ihren
beiden Töchtern sie fast zerriss,
geht sie zurück in die Schweiz.
Beide hoffen,
dass er bald nachreisen kann.
Aber alles
hängt von seiner Gesundheit ab.
* Gefühlvolle Musik *
In der Schweiz wussten wir:
Hier sind wir sicher.
Wir haben alles, was wir brauchen.
Es geht uns gut.
Aber die Frage war schon,
wie wir uns absichern können
und wovon wir in Ghana leben werden.
Das Kulturzentrum war ein
gemeinsamer Traum von Mefia und Beda.
Er kann seine Leidenschaft für Musik
ausleben.
Und manchmal drückt auch durch,
dass er in der Schweiz
lange als Musiklehrer gearbeitet hat.
Mefia mag Menschen.
Sie geht auf im Umgang mit den Gästen
im Restaurant.
I really do.
- Really?
* Sie sprechen unverständlich. *
Auch für die fünf Angestellten
ist sie zuständig.
Und für die zehn Hotelzimmer.
Dabei wollte Mefia vor drei Jahren
gar nicht nach Ghana ziehen.
Aber Beda war überzeugt,
dass ein Wechsel richtig sei.
Ich sagte, ich sei nicht bereit.
Ja.
Er sagte aber, wir müssen.
He is the boss.
Und dann? Weshalb
bist du plötzlich trotzdem ...
Ich bin aus Ghana.
Ich kann nicht immer
in der Schweiz bleiben.
Das hast du gewusst?
- Ja.
Auch Beda wusste,
worauf er sich einlässt.
Nach seinem Musikstudium
lebte er ein Jahr lang in Ghana,
weil ihn die afrikanischen Trommeln
interessierten.
Die Schweiz und Ghana - zwei
komplett unterschiedliche Länder.
Es braucht Mut, eine Familie mit zwei
Schulkindern hierher zu verpflanzen.
Um das Kulturzentrum zu bauen,
löste Beda seine Pensionskasse auf.
Ihr Reihenhaus in der Schweiz
vermieten sie.
Das hilft,
um hier die Grundkosten zu decken.
* Afrikanische Popmusik *
Dafür kann Beda jetzt
Bubenträume wahr machen.
Der bekannte Musiker Atongo Zimba
war schon immer sein Idol.
Jetzt nimmt er mit ihm zusammen
ein Album auf.
Machst du das einfach gerne
und es gibt dir als Künstler viel,
oder verdienst du Geld damit?
Nein, ich verdiene kein Geld damit.
Ich muss es einfach
irgendwie machen.
Als Künstler
macht man gewisse Sachen einfach.
Und ...
Aber ... indirekt
verdiene ich doch Geld.
Dadurch,
dass es hier so coole Events gibt.
Er ist hier.
Allgemein ist hier viel los.
Das finden die Leute toll.
Dann übernachten sie vielleicht
hier. Das ist mein Businessplan.
* Fröhliches Pfeifen *
Die Musik ist auch im Leben
der beiden Söhne Evan und Levin
ein fester Bestandteil.
So.
Fängst du an?
Wer fängt an?
* Einzelne Klaviertöne *
Beda und Mefia unterstützen auch
Kinder aus armen Familien.
Damit diese in die Schule gehen
und Musik machen können.
* Unverständlicher Rap *
Pinky z.B. hat
dank des Projekts Danis Entertainment
schon verschiedene Preise gewonnen.
Musik kann eine Chance sein für ein
anderes, vielleicht besseres Leben.
Das war der Soundcheck für die Hits
der Kinder von Danis Entertainment,
die in einer Stunde
auftreten werden.
Also, bleibt hier
und nehmt noch einen Drink.
Danke, Pinky.
Mein Traumjob ist,
dass ich ein guter Musiker werde,
viel Youtube, Instagram
und andere Sachen mache.
Super.
Wenn du das möchtest, dann mach das.
Hier bist du am richtigen Ort dafür.
* Jubel, unverständliche Aussagen *
* Popmusik mit Gesang *
Ich hoffe, dass wir irgendwann
eine der besten Bands der Welt sind.
Ganz andere Pläne
hat Evans Bruder Levin.
Er möchte später
für ein Studium in die Schweiz.
Ich möchte definitiv
Medizin studieren.
Ich möchte Tierarzt werden.
* Rasante Musik *
Am Abend treten Bands auf,
die typische Musik
aus dem Norden Ghanas spielen.
Einmal mehr
gibt es eine lange Nacht bei beda's.
Liebe ist grenzenlos, sagt man.
Aber für Andrea und ihren Freund
sind Landesgrenzen
eine unüberwindbare Hürde.
Sie können erst zusammen sein,
wenn sie verheiratet sind.
Dazu brauchen sie viele Dokumente.
Heute aber
könnte sich endlich was tun.
Ich habe schon unzählige
Beruhigungstees getrunken.
Aber ja, irgendwie hilft es.
Ja.
Heute ist ein spezieller Tag.
Also ...
Es kann ein spezieller Tag werden.
Das wird sich noch rausstellen.
Jedenfalls mache ich mir
erst einmal einen Tee.
Die Marketingfachfrau Andrea
hat sich eine Auszeit genommen
und ist nach Kolumbien gereist.
Dort hat sie Pedro kennengelernt.
Lange Zeit
waren sie nur gute Freunde.
Pedro
kommt ursprünglich aus Venezuela.
In Kolumbien ist er Übersetzer
und leitet Touren
in die Ciudad Perdida,
die sagenumwobene Ruinenstadt.
Jaguar, Ozelot and Cougar.
How is work going?
Seit einem Jahr
sind er und Andrea jetzt ein Paar.
Aber ob ihre Liebesgeschichte
ein Happy End hat, ist offen.
Die beiden stecken
in einem endlosen Papierkrieg.
Es hiess mal,
sie seien mit der Post angekommen.
Ohne diese Dokumente geht nichts.
Ohne diese Dokumente können wir
keinen Visumsantrag stellen.
Wir können nichts machen.
Wir können nicht heiraten
ohne Visum, nicht zusammen sein.
Und darum ...
Hoffentlich heute.
Hoi.
Wie geht's?
- Gut. Und dir?
Okay. Aber aufgeregt.
Sind sie da?
Em ...
Yes.
Ich war heute Morgen auf der Post.
Sie sind hier.
Wirklich? Ist alles korrekt?
Okay.
Yay!
Auf vielen Seiten wir bestätigt:
"Ja, alles echt."
"Ja, er ist Single."
Mit vielen Apostillen.
* Sie lacht. *
Klar, hat das so lange gedauert.
Aber haben sie von allen
zwei geschickt?
Ja.
Eine mit und eine ohne Apostillen.
Warum?
Das kapiere ich nicht.
Dasselbe Dokument
einmal mit, einmal ohne Apostillen?
Weil es sonst teurer wäre
und mehr Zeit bräuchte.
* Sie seufzt. *
Aber dann sind wir bereit?
- Ausser der Übersetzung.
Wie lange dauert das?
Sie meinten, acht Tage.
Wir sind also einen Schritt weiter.
Wir haben immer noch
einen langen Weg vor uns.
Ja, eine Ewigkeit.
Ja.
Aber wir sind einen Schritt weiter.
Das ist am wichtigsten.
Ja.
Einen guten Tag wünsche ich dir.
Und viel Glück mit allem.
Ich hoffe, alles klappt.
Gute Nacht und träum schön.
- Okay.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
* Lateinamerikanisch anmutende,
heitere Musik *
Man muss damit leben lernen.
Mit den äusseren Umständen, die hier
härter sind als in der Schweiz.
Das ist so.
Und klar ...
Korruption,
ein Staat, der sich einen
Scheissdreck um die Leute kümmert.
Man muss es einfach selbst machen.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Ähm ...
Was machst du da?
Ich mache mir einen Kräutermedizin
gegen Würme im Fuss.
Würme im Fuss?
Es sind erst Larven. Sie bahnen sich
langsam durch meinen Fuss.
Ja.
Das sind die Bahnen,
wo sich die Larven durchfressen.
Hier sind sie wahrscheinlich
reingekommen.
Das ist Neem Tree.
Das soll sehr gut
gegen Malaria sein.
Aber ich habe trotzdem ...
... eine Malaria-Odyssee hinter mir,
obwohl ich das getrunken habe.
Hast du zuerst versucht,
Malaria mit Kräutern zu behandeln?
Bei Evan
habe ich es zuerst versucht.
Ich habe rumgefragt.
Sie sagten,
das gehe schon mit Kräutermedizin.
Wir wussten, dass es Malaria ist.
Dann gingen wir aber trotzdem
ins Spital.
Es war mir eine Lehre. Bei Symptomen
gehe ich sofort testen.
Und es hängt auch
von der Behandlung ab.
Hat man die Möglichkeit,
in ein Spital zu fahren?
Das Geld?
- Genau. Zugang zu Medikamenten.
Aber bei den Würmern will es Beda
nochmals mit Naturmedizin probieren.
Darf ich dir einen Shot anbieten?
Du musst jetzt einen nehmen.
- Nein!
Doch. Es ist wirklich sehr gesund.
Du musst ihn auf Ex trinken.
- Auf Ex?
Ich habe keine Würmer im Fuss.
- Nein. Das ist auch sonst gut.
Ah, ja.
- Es ist sehr bitter.
Am besten auf Ex.
Nicht wahr?
Powerful.
Wenn man daran nicht stirbt,
muss es helfen.
Ich tue das Ding drauf.
Mal schauen.
Schadet es nicht ...
... so nützt es nichts?
Wollte ich das sagen?
Ich kann meinen Vater
schnell anrufen
und fragen, ob die Kräuter
hier eine gute Idee sind.
Ja, genau.
Du hast quasi Telemed?
Dein Schweizer Medizinberater
ist dein Vater.
* Freiton *
Er hört es nicht.
Er hat noch
eine Sprachnachricht geschickt.
(Mann aus Telefon) Hoi, Beda.
Sehr wahrscheinlich ist das
ein sog. Hakenwurm, Larva migrans.
Ein Hakenwurm.
Ich habe dir per Mail einen Artikel
aus einer Ärztezeitung geschickt
und wie man es behandeln kann.
- Man kann es behandeln.
Aber du musst auf jeden Fall etwas
machen, sonst schwillt der Fuss an,
entzündet sich
und es gibt Komplikationen
Mhm.
Okay. Gute Besserung. Tschau, Beda.
Die gute Nachricht:
Man kann es behandeln.
Man kann etwas machen.
Dein Vater weiss Bescheid.
- Ja.
Der Hausarzt in Endingen kennt sich
auch mit Hakenwürmern in Ghana aus.
Ja.
* Instrumentalversion
von "Take my Hand" *
* Lachen *
* Herzschlag *
Endlich ist er da: der grosse Tag
für Brigitte und ihre Töchter.
Sie warten bereits auf ihre Mutter,
die heute aus den USA zurückkommt.
Aufgeregt, es ist irgendwie unreal,
dass sie für immer zurückkommt.
Es ist schön, zu wissen,
dass Mama wieder in der Nähe ist,
dass man schnell vorbeigehen kann,
wenn man eine Umarmung braucht.
11 Min. sind vorbei.
Sie muss wohl
noch das Gepäck finden.
Sie hat zwei Koffer.
* Freudenschrei *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Hoi.
Ist es gut gegangen?
* Lachen *
Welcome back in Switzerland.
Ich habe euch so vermisst.
* Sie seufzt. *
Du siehst gut aus.
- Danke.
Ich bin so happy.
Ich habe mich so nach diesem Tag
gesehnt.
Ich habe so oft geträumt,
dass ich hier sei.
Dann bin ich aufgewacht und dachte:
"Oh, Mist."
Sie habe ich
zwischendurch mal gesehen,
aber sie habe ich vier Jahre
nicht mehr gesehen.
Vor zehn Jahren ging ich,
damals waren sie Teenager.
Und jetzt sind es erwachsene Frauen.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Hin und weg":
Wie Mathias den Schweizer Zopf
nach China bringt.
(Englisch)
Sie ist Meisterin im Zopfflechten.
(Englisch) Oh, wie schön.
Die Heimbäckerei
wird immer professioneller
und beansprucht immer mehr
der sowieso schon knappen Freizeit.
* Hupen *
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Hello.
Brigitte ist in Langenthal angekommen
und lebt sich ein.
Aber Jay fehlt ihr überall.
(Englisch) Wie geht's dir?
- (Jay) Viel besser.
Ah, gut.
Die Leute hier sind alle sehr nett.
Es wird uns sehr gefallen.
Mach das Bett bereit,
ich bin bald da.
Es ist verrückt.
Und wir lernen Angie und Tom kennen.
In Ecuador hat der ehemalige Banker
seine Traumfrau gefunden.
Der Weg zueinander war nicht einfach.
Tom gibt alles,
um sich zu integrieren.
(Spanisch) Ist das die Zunge?
Man möchte gegenüber der Schwieger-
mutter nicht das Gesicht verlieren
und muss eben
in den sauren Apfel beissen
und dann halt
ein, zwei Häppchen essen.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me,
# take my hand.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
D. Zacheo, M. Hoss - 2022